yeah let me honest with you no one in
the right mind would review doom now or
any game really now that everyone's mind
is on e3 stuff alas I'm not a smart man
I'm not a wise man I'm barely even a
clever man so let's review the new doom
doom so doom is a reinvigoration of the
old-school doom that we all knew and
loved from the 90s if you were alive if
you are a gamer from the 90s he'll
probably even after that it's just fun
stuff to do basically this doom exists
to recapture the magic of the old doom
which is an explorative game where you
flip a switch or you grab a carrier you
get an item and a bunch of enemies just
start pouring in walls drop and you have
to take on an onslaught of
enemies with the ammo and guns you have
whom should be a lot of shooting a lot
of enemies on screen a lot of sweating a
lot of intensity happy to say this game
does recapture that I had a blast
playing doom yeah there is a pretty
light story in this doom and that would
piss me off if I was here for a story
but I just wasn't I was here for the
gameplay the story is basically what you
knew from the old doom zlatan Mars we
had a science facility and they start
dabbling into tech from hell because
it's gonna help them and then literally
all hell breaks loose on Mars and now
you're on a first person shooter
adventure that takes you from Mars hell
and back but bring on the demons and
guns man because that's why we are here
really it's like one of the early levels
in this game it's called the foundry and
there are these little pods these hell
pods and you rip something out of this
hell pod you just here and then demons
and imps just start pouring in and you
just have to take them out it is intense
[ __ ] man the great thing is when you get
to the end of game you want to explore
and find all the secrets you have all
the guns all the endgame weapons and you
can go back and really wreck the enemies
from the earthly levels even the monster
designs in this game we're exactly what
I wanted them to be it's like if they
ever made a doom movie like a good do
movie not that thing I would want the
demons and monsters in that doom movie
to look exactly like they looked in here
because if someone showed me a picture
of the demons in this game and they're
like alright what's that I'd be like oh
that's that's a baron of Hell or that's
an import it's the pinky bulldog that is
a pinkies in this one they're dicks I
remember in doom 2 man just blast blasts
from that double barrel shock on those
little Bulldogs just drop this one no
they straight up like bulb bull charged
you and it takes out some armor and it
hurts so the point is just by looking at
you know exactly what you're going up
against they do you have a couple new
guns in this game and a couple new
enemies in this game you know just keeps
it fresh they have new stuff it's not in
a complete rehash of the enemies and
guns bold and in the end it doesn't
matter because that super shotgun you
soup that thing up and it's all you will
ever need ever yeah there are a lot of
Secrets in this game and it's attainable
- this is one of the very few platinum
trophies on my ps4 played on ps4 that I
actually have there are these rooms and
these room challenges have a logistic of
some sort of like I take out all the
enemies with exploding barrels before
the time runs out you know things like
that the last couple of runes they make
you work for it but when you get it
up life is good I believe it's the last
rune in the game it's you have that rune
if you have it equipped if you have over
a hundred armor and you upgrade it to
where it's if you have over 75 armor you
have unlimited ammo feels a bit cheap
but you did earn the rune nothing says
you have to use the room but when you
walk into a room full of enemies with
that rune on you are straight up like
just going around boom boom mo doesn't
matter animal doesn't matter super
shotgun
guaranteed to make you feel better about
whatever in life is bothering you is
[ __ ] demons man come on oh yeah and I
like that about the trophies in this
game there are some trophies I look at
have you ever seen the twisted metal
trophies for ps3 screw that noise I'm
never doing that [ __ ] right when I
looked at it I was like nope whatever
I'm not even really a platinum
completionist but in this game just like
Mortal Kombat X another one I have a
platinum and I looked at it I was like
that's attainable and I appreciate that
it's not really [ __ ] up
out-of-this-world logistics just explore
have fun hone your skills and you can
get the Platinum I don't know in a world
of some impossible Platinum's I just
enjoyed the fact that this one's
actually attainable if you do your [ __ ]
even the weapon upgrade system wasn't
glaringly overly complicated nothing I
don't like involved upgrading systems in
some games I'm just saying if the weapon
upgrading system in Doom was too
cumbersome and I felt like I needed a
four-year degree to even do it I've been
glaring would have taken away from the
fun of doom but they keep it simple yet
effective optimal for a game like this
find Secrets you get points you get
points you upgrade your weapons upgrade
it down to the last tier in the last
here is a logistic of some sort so I'm
going to kill two or more enemies with
one shot 15 times so now you can shoot
your super shotgun your double-barrel
shotgun twice before you even have to
reload it makes all the difference in
the world some of the upgrades kind of
broke the game when you have your super
souped out Gatling gun all upgraded so
it never overheats and you have your
room giving it unlimited ammo look man
ain't complaining many a demon fell at
my hand
I'm just saying broke the game a bit
there's actually a level maker in here
it's kind of like I kind of attributed
to if you had a Mario game and that
Mario game had a Mario maker type thing
just built into it's like hey you have
your whole Mario game here here's some
Mario maker didn't go online play levels
and stages that other people have
created is actually pretty fun that's
actually the online [ __ ] that I actually
like in this doom game because there is
a multiplayer I get why the multiplayer
beta was really panned by peoples like
ah dooms gonna suck and in tube came out
like no no no the campaign is actually
pretty sweet its multiplayer in a
first-person shooter I mean what is
going to be in this that you haven't
seen a zillion and a half times before
nothing that's what I could say if you
came for the multiplayer you're gonna be
disappointed if you came for the story
you're gonna be disappointed if you came
for some really sweet exciting ass
gameplay you're going to have fun with
doom guaranteed point is this is the
most fun in the first
shooter I have had in years hands down I
can say that with a straight face when I
wasn't home I just wanted to get back
home so I could play doom again I have
played all the missions in this game
multiple times over easily four or five
times each you know these stages like
the back ear hand by the time you're
done solid gameplay I'm looking forward
to what they do for doom too it does
leave it open for a sequel I hope it's
successful I hope in the next doom game
the difficulty are at least the the
enemies that come waving in at you I
hope it scales example when you do the
foundry for the fifth time and you have
all the endgame weapons it's not really
that hard no more you're like Oh imps
double-barrel shotgun with unlimited
ammo bam bam you're all dead which I'm
fine with
imps but if you're coming back from the
end of the game I just want to see more
imps it's like I have all the enemies in
that stage but just have more waves of
them I'd like to see that in Doom 2 but
we'll see what happens
- guys doom absolutely is awesome
tacular alright guys so the new doom
have you played it what did you think
about it how does it compare to the old
dooms for you whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
you